we're playing Red Dead Redemption 2 a
game that my good friend ing has
recommended we met in Austin
but she's now in Boston Cambridge
working on exoskeletons and robotic
Limbs and robotic limbs
which in the future I guess would be
cyborgs we started playing it a little
bit ago
and it's way better than I
imagined because I thought the dialogue
is great
but just even the Dynamics of horses
because I thought it's just gonna be
Grand Theft Auto on a horse
but there's so much more to this game
well right now we're in story mode if we
played free play we could find a random
horse and train it
was cool that the horse gets tired you
have to take care of it
just the harsh conditions of snow as a
good as a start of the story is
incredible anyway we're ridden a horse
you're laughing because there's a
picture of me on the internet on a horse
okay I'm not sure there's gonna be a lot
of shoot is it why to take out the gun
[Laughter]
no why did I get off the horse okay
check your pockets
oh you've got your binoculars I know you
have in your pocket but the the gun I
don't know I don't know if you have any
weapons
what happened what happened to our
I don't know but I wasn't here all I did
is I played it for like five more
minutes and I Shot The Wolves they were
attacking
oh the Wolves
that's how you wasted all of your ammo
there's like five of them it was
difficult to shoot down
it took you five minutes
no I did yeah it was five minutes
because it's just one little Chase but
it took me like three attempts because I
was trying to get better at aiming
because I kept
it kept killing the other guy
oh it's a bit of a fight
it's like we're about to go and just
come back anyway I mentioned Austin how
do you remember how we met
how long ago was this it was like
a year and a half ago I think
in the summer right mm-hmm
I came to visit some friends
and I was at a coffee shop and we ran
into each other yeah
and that was uh
and then since then and when did you go
to MIT that was recent right very recent
that was in September
it's been fun the winter is very cold
though
this is their first cold place right
yeah and I love the heat like the Texas
heat was great
96 degrees walking on the trail yeah
it's nice I love it
I don't know
Dolby uh
oh you have a gun
nice okay so how uh how do you do the
you know like you can swap through the
different guns you have how do you think
you could flip through it
no
I don't need guns I use fist bro
okay but the revolver might be enough
approach our horse
I think it's more entertaining when you
play this because I'm so bad at it it's
just so great I mean it's just an
incredibly gorgeous game just like the
snow the sound of it I also put it on
cinematic mode which does what it's just
the views of it it's not really first
person it's not as pleasant for playing
the game but it's Pleasant for watching
someone else play
okay is this not my horse
just for the record we're both
noobs at this game but it's more fun
this way yeah
okay horse weapons
I saw that you can skin animals
there's a lot of RT to cycle
oh there we go yeah there you go I told
you how do you decide RT cool
okay
why do I need to go why do I still need
to do this
I remember like it was yesterday all the
Wolves I killed with that our needs
right now are supplies
nice twirl everything else including
calm and wait okay
this guy walks really slow as it is now
come on
I don't think these guys are in touch
with their feminine side why don't you
think that
just everything they're doing is like
the most their coats are pretty long
true
it's pretty fun man look good for you
killed crawling over a skirt I guess I
killed season what do you think about
kills
um I think they're pretty awesome
I mean it's pretty aggressive could take
buy one but
yeah if you're not Scottish
in general
it's just like an aggressive movement if
you have one Boston yeah and a kilt a
giant coat that killed I mean
I don't wear a skirt in the winter I
think I can go to the gym in a kilt this
workout let's do curls like you're kind
of stinky
when I get kicked out from like Planet
Fitness if I wore a kill I mean well you
have to think about it this way like
would I get kicked out of Planet Fitness
if I wore a skirt to the gym
I don't think they think of it that way
they'll just see me in a kilt it's like
excuse me sir
you're scaring you're scaring everyone
and you're making all kinds of sounds
you would make sounds while you're
wearing it yeah to make this sound
like like William Wallace
I'll paint my face blue whatever and
Stripes Braveheart
wow
it's cheesy as hell but it's Epic
a great speech
is it it's a good like monologue
no he does a speech where
they're The Underdogs and they have to
fight the British and
he basically says like we can run and
keep our lives
oh we can stand here and fight
for our freedom
and the question is
you have to imagine years from now when
you're in your deathbed and you're
looking back
would you come back here for just one
more chance
to fight instead of fleeing it's a good
speech
gotta be brave
yeah
sometimes you have to put your life in
the line bravery is important
I was talking to my nephew about this
recently
so he plays uh I think it's called
Minecraft yeah and uh there's zombies in
the game and he knows a way of like
escaping whatever conflict he's in so
that he doesn't have to face it and I
told him that in life it's really
important to be brave because you can't
always run away from your problems so I
think bravery is super important
what are they saying should I take the
lead or should I send the Gang
uh what do you mean you have those
options I have those options no I take
the leads and the Gang send the Gang
uh lead from the back
all right should we just
oh shoot where's where are the people oh
that's right
I didn't see the DOT
this screen is humongous yeah that's
ridiculous
should I bring the thing closer no it's
good oh shoot I keep on getting shot how
do I hide
oh this is getting real hold on how do I
crouch again
sometimes you have to put just like you
said that you have to put your life in
line
it's worth it it's worth it at the end
retry checkpoint don't restart the
mission which is this an a a
oh you have to hold it
nice yeah because restarting the mission
we're gonna go through that whole
walking thing so what is it is it wide
no to take out the gun
this is really hard I know
you try it
oh
oh that was me
that wasn't you that was me yeah that
was you me it was animating your your
death shot yeah it did so good
nice
oh there's no one there all right where
are the people
oh
nice
oh where are the who is it
[Music]
imagining things
I don't know
but I figured it out now okay all right
what are we doing this
by the minute becoming more and more of
a cowboy
excess
where's the set do you know uh I don't
know
I could look it up oh my phone's
charging somewhere over there
did you hear what he said I don't go
down that easy and he just shot him
twice yeah
just to prove a point
sounds like you're clean
oh I need to eat oh yeah all right cool
hold on what am I here
how do I switch over
oh I see okay
I think lb to use
okay did that help
all right I wanna eat
Oh shoot no no no no no no everything is
fine
just keep dying
oh what I restarted the mission yeah
because restarting the mission we're
gonna go through that whole walking
thing
come on
couple of days on the land that's good
gives us a chance to relive
the incredible Graphics of this video
game
going faster were you pressing a while
you were on the horse
yeah but not enough
I haven't figured out if you can just
hold it or if you have to keep pressing
it it's complicated
I don't think I'm controlling it anymore
yeah
this is gorgeous yeah it's really
beautiful
have you ridden horses yeah I used to go
to a horseback riding camp
I like it loved it
I like horses a lot they're very gentle
they're kind of like
well they're they're better than dogs in
a way like they're more loyal and they
don't realize how large they are
they're really just sweet
for horses
things I can forgive others I can forget
what he did to him there's so many
cliche things and this is great
this is like a mix of Grand Theft Auto
and Skyrim because the nature scenes are
beautiful it's not always winter right
it goes
well I think that I remember a version
where it was winter
yeah someone cleaned it went well
see that smoke I'm sure the seasons
change in the game
winter is brutal
crazy you're not so you're not enjoying
like the craziness of it at least a
little bit I mean I think it's like
it's bonding for the people that live
there you get to complain yeah because
they get to complain together
but
and you get to appreciate deeper when
it's actually when it's like a different
season yeah yeah when the seasons change
it is beautiful when it snows we
recently it was a weekend where it was
like negative 11 degrees or something
crazy
you ever Build a Snowman
uh once but when I was younger have you
yeah all the time all the time yeah I
used to uh really enjoy eating snow and
then people will tell me you shouldn't
do that and I said I would still do it
why did you keep doing it just the
rebellion and you're yeah you couldn't
live it tastes good
I see
it tastes good
I don't know do you chew on ice too no
no it's like it's refreshing but I think
it's probably horrible for you
because all kinds of stuff would be in
the snow
I don't think I was so much concerned
about my
health or immune system when I was young
probably made it stronger yeah probably
because these days they're not eating
enough snow
they don't know what it was like what's
the scariest thing you've ever done
scariest skydiving she just gotta I've
gone skydiving
um
I think probably scuba diving because I
didn't know I didn't take a class or
anything and I was
scuba diving
and um
we went under the water and there was
Stingrays and it was like this really
weird feeling of like this may go very
wrong but I feel like the people around
me are very confident so they'll take
care of me if something happens that's
the same thing for skydiving for me yeah
huh
have you ever killed a man no have you
yeah
I'm really taking this game
the spirit of this game
just killed many Cowboys my day if you
had the opportunity to live in this time
for like a year would you
like a vacation
yeah yeah but you no you have to stay
for a whole year though whole year I
would do it
my lab they do this thing where they go
to Africa and they help people and you
stay for a month but it's like these
really harsh conditions
I think two of the girls that recently
went they got really sick while they
were there but you're helping these
people don't have access to these limbs
yeah probably
also helps you appreciate yeah
everything that you have access to
readily
you guys are suspiciously close together
you know we're like okay
are you thinking about John
all right let's go wait wait why isn't
it letting me
all right oh that's what it was I only
had breakfast
you're dead he's such a business
[Music]
oh shoot
nice
I really want to get this guy
okay all right come on
obviously we're not very good at this
game
oh
it's kind of fun let's just keep we just
keep dying the same but like hey how
about this what uh
yeah a restart checkpoint okay
[Laughter]
read that out I quit the restart Mission
by accident that's true what do you
think about like cyborgs you think you
think in 100 years we'll all be
partially worldwide yeah I think we have
to merge with technology
in order to like
in order to
um evolve with it because it's evolving
so quickly if we don't evolve with it
it's like we lose a step in evolution
yeah it's like it's the logical Next
Step including brain yeah CCIS and bmis
are the future
see like you like The Yearling stuff
love it
love it there's a lot of awesome your
link people here in Austin they're
saying they're um don't they want to
give me a tour and meet them and stuff I
really don't meet them and the surgeon
have to talk to a few surgeons they're
just incredible people I love it yeah
and the cool thing about yearling is
they have all these like different why
do they stop crouching I don't know
that's fine crouching is good I feel
like you're definitely safer yeah
but you you know you look less gangster
but you know it's fine
the the cool things they got like all
kinds that they got materials
engineering people they got lots of cool
robotics obviously software engineering
they have like
they have to take care of the animals
that's a whole thing yeah that's tough I
mean I deal with a lot of animal stuff
in our lab too like with the rats
the rats are a lot nicer than the mice
oh but I think they're dealing with
monkeys right
yeah they're no they're doing everything
they're doing my stew I think with the
monkeys and they they make them super
happy and pigs too
I think gigafactory opening there's a
there's like an animal zoo you can rent
you can rent folks that
like they'll bring a bunch of animals
and you get to play with them they're
petting petting like it's a it's a cool
thing for a party
if you just order a bunch of animals you
get to pet them like a goat and a bunny
you're talking about fighting Zeus yeah
but the portable like you can bring it
to your party yeah
those exist they usually come to like
children's parties yeah it was awesome
yeah they're great I will forever be a
child
do you see any bad guys because nobody
hears someone shooting where
they're shooting at someone
I feel like they're just shooting
shooting they're like
trying to look cool they're shooting for
the gram
I don't know
I keep going to the gun range
it's like me wearing the uh
The Kilt at the gym I think I might eat
the protein bar that's in your fridge
it's not it's like can I just have a
bite of it because I feel like my blood
sugar is really low okay
it's not that good is it does this have
sugar in it
sadly not maybe I'll drink some of it
maybe it'll help me
I killed I killed the last of them the
last of what of the Powerade things no
no the the last guy you did yeah yeah
okay let me just sit
I think they actually the AI in this
game is pretty shitty because you
couldn't
um didn't pick up they were just
shooting around they couldn't figure out
what the enemy is and the enemy couldn't
figure out what the good guys are
and kill with that thought you're in
whoa
why did you buy that one
what do you mean
protein worm
uh
uh because I went out yesterday and it
was
past midnight and I didn't wasn't sure
where to get food
so that's what you decided to eat yeah
it was ambitious I got a different
flavor and it was pretty good oh
what are they shooting at oh there you
go there you go
am I still shooting at somebody oh
Advance or defund
yes
not all men truly live
I shouldn't you should Mount the horse
well I think would be more fun and
quicker but you don't look as cool look
how I'm walking no cover not crouching
anymore not crouching
yeah
you've made me angry when I get angry
I don't Crouch
your play Shooters like Call of Duty
uh I'm not as into it I like when
there's a story
no with Call of Duty like I think
there's a
story mode
like single player there is there is but
it's more like
it's a lot of like this but not as
Scenic yeah yeah it's also a little bit
more military so if you're into that
kind of thing I don't know which
direction I'm being shot from
it doesn't show you
on the map oh I guess not
they're running away
yeah I took care of everything thank you
what would I do without you I know
I didn't just chill with the guys I
think
oh we're going into different buildings
detonators explosives nice
okay
[Music]
I like that we're delegating duties here
right I mean if there's anything I love
to do in a game it is forage
that's pretty fun you can do all of the
fighting
I'm not good at fighting in this either
for learning this looks good
what do you think Bill I like the weed
in that feels like a team
this is great
come on I really thought
this game will be way worse think so
boss found this well you didn't like
Zelda so I think that's why yeah we
should mention we'll play Zelda for a
little bit before and it was too um
it's too fun let's do Adventure
it's too shallow
you like the Accents in this game better
yeah this game is gritty it's like yeah
it feels like a movie I'd want to watch
[Music]
do you think you were a cowboy in a past
life
what made you decide what the guy would
answer me
no I was
um
I was more of a
carrot farmer
like some very insignificant vegetable
um
no you know what not a cowboy because
the Cowboys are the good guys usually
right
I think so
or I mean I was a bank robber
bank robber
do you so you think that like being a
criminal would be a lot of fun
yeah I like the challenge of it yeah I
don't like the murder but sometimes you
have to do what you have to do to get
the job done it's like a puzzle I'm just
speaking like a cowboy with it
no no I think it's actually would be in
this context super challenging too
without hurting anybody to steal money
but you're gonna hurt that's very
stressful
if you have a bank in a small town at
that time you're probably hurting a lot
of people
you think so you think you have to kill
someone no I mean like financially oh
yeah that town is probably dependent on
the bank
although like um
really good show Yellowstone
oh that's a great show it's a great show
I've seen it you've seen it yeah there's
Cowboys it's more like a modern I mean
it's you know
without going into Cowboy sounding
cliches there's a certain kind of ethic
and value system you live under
that I think is in part admirable
oh I clicked the wrong thing
what happened
oh we didn't get there in time oh
sorry we were chatting too much yeah
whatever it's just beautiful I like kind
of chilling and walking around this
world does he make you sad that we'll
have cyborgs and robots and AI
no I think if we merge with it we have a
really
optimistic looking future
but you're gonna lose some of the this
kind of cowboy humanness you know well I
think that
your humanness will be enhanced like the
same way that you know
money makes you rich sure but it just
amplifies whatever type of person you
are I think it'll be the same thing with
AI like it's just a current it's
it's amplifying whatever interests you
have so if you're very interested in I
don't know art you're going to be able
to download
all of our history and have access to it
at any time that you need it
was that the guy that I was supposed to
shoot
no
oh
well I think so
hurting Toby this is don't hurt me
is he dying or is that like I mean
reverse psychology or what
he has to die
I'm supposed to kill him
damn it oh no two words
oh no
I think we're not paying attention to
the mission I think it's better that way
I think it's more entertaining yeah I
thought for sure he was trying to trick
you
yeah I'm definitely excited about AI but
you have to be
you definitely have to be cautious
especially about which companies get the
control of it
I like the more companies the more
people have control
supervisor control over AI systems the
better
distributed
that's the cool thing about Chad gbt is
like it's pretty easy to build
relatively speaking
so a lot of companies will be doing it
the hell is wrong with you
oh no you don't I just I didn't answered
him how'd you know that
wait did you do that yeah I did
what wait oh wait what did I do hold on
why is it going this way okay that
started so nice I know that really went
well
don't hurt me okay hold on why is the
horse LT ready to last I'll throw the
last RT cool
okay I think you killed him no press B
near
hog tying him oh nice
he's really uh playing dead for you yeah
nice he's done
hold back soon
all right
are we kidnapping him
I think so
approach the back of your horse and hold
X to Stow him
yeah okay I don't really think it's
kidnapping one he's like he's broke and
dying in the middle of the Wilderness I
think you're saving him honestly all
right let's get back on the horse I
guess
thank you
I don't know you don't know your name
boy Duffy Karen Duffy well
ain't gonna lie to you
oh this winter is brutal
I think people will have relationships
with AI systems yeah
because the AIS py but I think guess
your needs very quickly but I think
it'll get boring
I think it'll be it'd be too perfect
yeah
would you date a robot
um maybe maybe for a little bit I I
don't think it would be as fun as dating
a human though especially if humans
merge with technology sure
fun isn't it has anything worried
yeah I suspect the robots would be too
perfect
but if it's
I think the the human merging with the
AI would be very interesting combo yeah
I agree
because then you wouldn't have this
laggy brain that's like forgetting
things
you would have more interesting
conversations and you would have like
all of your passions you would be able
to dive in deep to them and then come up
with really great ideas on how to
explore those ideas and research would
become more intuitive I think
yeah it's a tricky thing because you
want some like life should still have
some Challenge and it feels like a lot
of our development happens in the face
of challenge
or we just find new challenges with a
even though we gained extra abilities
we'll still find stuff that's
challenging
real nice
I got him very good
welcome to your new home hope you're
real happy here
this guy does not sound nice
oh now all we'll get is lies Uncle Mr
Williamson tie this maggot up someplace
safe we get them hungry first I got a
saying my friend
who shoot fellas is need shooting
saved fellas is need saving and feed
them is need feeding we are gonna find
out what you need
I can't believe it I know Driscoll in my
Camp I ain't no joke is that how you
dress in in Boston
pretty much
it's too cold
I would always
under dress did you yeah were you
driving a lot no I didn't didn't have a
car you do uh thread line and bus
I love it I love taking the tea
but I I do bus much more
and stand on the bus stop freezing
there's an intimacy there's a romance to
the bus
there is some romance to standing
outside while it's cold out yeah like
you're you're bearing this cold but why
like what is it that you're doing that's
so important that you need to be facing
these elements
but you're also together with other
people that are just standing there and
suffering and all pretending like we're
now suffering but we're suffering yeah
but then we're not really suffering
because it's just cold it's just
temporary too yeah
you know I never understood the romance
of like people would always post like
winter in Miami and then post a picture
of them on the beach oh I see they're
troll yeah wait didn't you do that I've
never done that play I feel like you
sent me I probably recently did that
like winter maybe oh because you're now
boss you feel like you've earned the
right to yeah yeah I got you we're gonna
starve to death up here Mr Morgan
we're okay
we have a few cans of food and a rabbit
for what 10 12 people
when I was in the Navy I I do not I was
thinking about the um
the barbecue
that was so good should we go back
should I think so I'm very up for that
for the record went Tara Black's
Barbecue was really good
it's really really good oh it's so good
I don't it's funny you take for granted
because I haven't just haven't gone in a
while it's so delicious where do you
usually go
I just go to like restaurants or just
eat at home because it like
I don't know why it's almost like too
delicious but it's like a treat yeah it
should be like a tree but it's not
really not uh it is really special
though when you do have it
like because I feel like it takes a
while to prepare that kind of food yeah
like they're smoking it all day right
and I like it because like when visitors
come and you
go to like Terry blacks and you do the
barbecue and you it's crazy it's so good
and because there's so many like the bar
is so high and then they still deliver
yeah that's cool
and it's consistently great like every
time you go it's amazing
you know one time my dad and I went my
dad used to do his residency here and he
was so excited he was like I can't wait
to go have barbecue I'm so excited
you're gonna live in Texas all the stuff
we ate way too much and we got so sick
afterwards
that's the challenge
there's a few Tech
um
Tech folks here they're really cool they
went out with them but we got trashed
like whiskey just so drunk and what I
didn't realize is when I'm that drunk
the whatever module in my brain that
says don't stop eating was off yeah
because your body is so relaxed and I'm
having fun and then all of a sudden it's
a good idea to order like 10 pounds of
meat and then you're just not just me
like everybody together or just eating
eating and just and it's it's so hard to
stop because it's so freaking delicious
and then you're drunk but
that's happiness it's delicious yeah
it's great it's great while you're
eating it you know what I've noticed
about unhealthy Foods or like treats
it's always really fun while you're
eating it but before and after
there's always this feeling of like
regrets yeah or like um like before you
eat a cupcake or something I always feel
this feeling of like I'm Really Gonna
regret this after I eat it but I really
want it and then while I'm eating it I'm
like enjoying it I'm like oh this is so
good I want like another one and then
afterwards I'm like why did I do that
yeah
I have to really work on that to walk
away walk away while like you really
want a thing and you say nope no more
ah that looks beautiful look at that
um I have yeah I did like grew up
cross-country skiing like I'm you know
not downhill
because they're really good with the
mountains you don't know oh yeah aren't
they the ones that they yeah they stand
on the edges of the oven in a goat oh
yeah what's your best what's your
favorite
really bad meal that you shouldn't be
eating my favorite really bad meal that
I shouldn't be eating
um
like something naughty uh
probably like fried chicken
I love fried chicken oh I think I've had
much Fried Chicken to talk about like
KFC like no so there's this grocery
store in Miami it's called Publix and
they have the best fried chicken like
it's so good oh like the in like that
little spot that keeps it yes yep and
it's so good and they have like chicken
tenders crispy and all that oh it's so
good
it's great with sauce of some kind no
sauce I'm not a sauce person
okay well that's no respect no I'm not
no I'm not Saucy at all I'm just giving
you respect oh the people that cover
yourself with sauce with the people that
finding the sauces 100 the people that
I'll have people here in Texas who are
like
legit barbecue
like aficionados whatever you call that
the selectable they will put sauce on
their bark they'll like dip it and stuff
they'll have like different sauces right
I did that the last time I make it you
did I put a little bit was
disrespecting the meats it's just not
cool it's like putting ketchup on a on a
steak on an aged I don't judge people
for putting sauce but for certain things
it sounds like you're very emotionally
charged with this for anything except
pudding sauce yeah putting sauce in
their barbecue it's the one thing I
judge them on no I don't care but it is
I like I like what am I looking great
basic ingredients
why is it all slow motion uh because I
activated Eagle Eye I just don't know
what I'm looking for
it's a problem is I keep chatting with
you thank you
oh shoot
okay all right check it out oh it's
there okay oh cool it has uh what is
that
it's like a scent what is it
making too much noise
we're looking for an animal okay so then
we focus on the track
and then
so all you have to do is press RB while
focusing on the track I just don't know
where the track went no oh there we go
oh stop tracking I see
it's a giant TV and the text is blurry
I'm pretty sure my vision doesn't suck
that bad no it's definitely I think it's
just too much stimuli like it's like
just a giant screen you don't know where
to look giant screen a low resolution or
something I don't know what it is
qualities
oh yeah oh yeah
is there any other ones
we'll get them go get the meat
I don't know how to uncrouch you press
this button
oh okay
what a man handle it
I like how you did the hunting and I'm
not doing the Gathering the Gathering oh
hey hey what the
wouldn't it tell me to do stuff with it
no you have to look for more deer okay
why is he crouching
looks like he's really trying to leave
stealth
anyway uh besides Fried Chicken what
what else
um I love sweets so I love chocolate
dark
I'm a milk chocolate girl but I love
dark chocolate yeah me too
I'm a milk chocolate girl because uh I
don't know it was yeah so much creamier
yeah yeah it's more delicious but then
like the sophisticated people
how do I run yeah chocolate's not bad
like hot dark chocolate was like uh like
some nut butter in it but people will
judge you because like the real like if
you're a real chocolate person you're
gonna do dark chocolate because it's
like the more sophisticated complicated
flavor right that's like fake that's
like that's like someone going to I
don't know some restaurant and being
like if you don't order this then you
didn't really go to that place I don't
think that really matters I think it's
all subjective say with like coffee I
still drink instant coffee
do you like instant coffee yeah I don't
think I've ever had instant I don't like
to admit it because people say that
because they don't consider instant
coffee real coffee but I'm like it's
it's coffee
reliable like it's I can count on it I
know the flavor
it's good I know the amount
the aroma like this the the the whole
point of caught not the whole point did
you make it with hot water yeah with hot
water with hot water hot water I'm just
running around
not that way what are you doing how do
you know I just asked you oh so I should
follow this guy but he's just crouching
well you have to use your Eagle Eye
what's the Eagle Eye thing
so these two you click them down at the
same time
and you got to look around because
you're going to run out of Eagle Eye
why do I I think we lost the animal hold
on
cancel it okay
wait
don't do it yet
go back to where that animal was and
then look for the all right
then look for the Sun
chocolate
what are your favorites
like something naughty though because
you eat very clean I don't think
I use the word naughty to describe it
we're describing food it makes me
uncomfortable does it it's such a weird
word to use I'm feeling naughty I don't
think I feel naughty
it's not I think that's not that's just
not in my vocabulary the thought yeah
uh is this back is this where it is
I think he likes the view I don't know
oh okay so the animals over there so get
close to it and then just look around
and I'm sure you'll find
I love baking by the way actually baking
yeah yeah
cookie so cookies like oatmeal raisin
that's the best cookies only reason I've
got a lot of trouble over there yeah I
went to war on Twitter over this is your
chocolate chip girl yeah all right so
I'm doing uh opening reason for me like
warm oatmeal raisin so one of my nephews
really loves oatmeal raisin the other
one loves chocolate chips one of my my
following is that yeah that's a scent
anyway oatmeal isn't cookie like a thick
almond resin cookie thick yeah yeah
the thin ones are like it makes no sense
because it's not what are you getting
like yeah there's not enough like
meat it's substance to the cookie good
job
just like a warm thick oatmeal raisin
cookie with some milk
it's your jam with with almond milk
actually from almond milk yeah with a
cookie the creamy almond milk or like
creamy real almond milk I don't know
what real almond milk is yeah real real
but not not sweet not sweet
unsweetened
wait what's that looking for the horse
gotta take this deer on the horse oh
there it is
nice
this horse is great so what's your
favorite cookie chocolate chip yeah I
love a chocolate chip cookie because
there's so many different ways of making
it I'm sure there's the same thing for
yeah no I'm gonna grab it I have to move
the horse okay so I had the option to
grab it so you can make like
cakey chocolate chip cookies sure you
can make like a gooey chocolate chip
cookie you can make a sugary one maybe
chewy gooey chewy gooey
um it depends on what like you can add
molasses you want to crumble or do you
want it to be chewy I don't like cooked
crispy I like chewy yeah good good
job there's a you know growing up
and uh
I think it's like in the Soviet Union
they had um
I think there's a kind of cake I don't
know how these call it in English but
it's
just an ant hill cake I think is it like
an angel hair cake no it's a condensed
milk
oh with a bunch of yellow condensed milk
yes of course of course I'm Cuban oh
let's check on this salad I don't do
Cubans do this kind of thing what do
they use it for you use it for a lot of
different things but desserts desserts
yes you can also yeah you can make a lot
of different things with it it's
delicious yeah it's amazing it's like
very sweet and gooey okay
it's the cake with uh I don't know it's
it's called Ant Hill people can look it
up it's great and it was just a source
of happiness because my mom will make it
every year for my birthday so oh that's
delicious
but then you like
as you grow up you realize like oh this
is probably really bad for you
yeah it is great
and I'm the only one that eats it so
when she makes it it's like all right am
I gonna do like this 20 000 calorie
Contraption am I really going to take
this on and I do because I can't do a
slice of it no yeah let's just keep
going the gods of cake
the damn
so your mom likes to bake too
what else did she bake what else does
she like what is your
favorite thing like a home-cooked meal
you know it's like I don't I think it's
just being with family is the favorite
thing versus like a specific meal
probably like barbecuing like
you know I'll usually Grill I'll make me
like
so just getting together around a grill
and then enjoying the meal with yeah and
then just drink like whiskey vodka yeah
I feel that way about traveling like
people romanticize going to different
places but I think it's really about the
company that you keep
it almost feels like we're having a
conversation but we're actually on a
horse having a conversation it does feel
like no worse
so which one of mine which one are you I
think they look the same
look how big that deer is black and
white horse yeah
it's kind of incredible this game just
looks beautiful yeah it's like realistic
watch out
bear up ahead
let's see if we can find another way
around
wait did you say bear yeah what do we do
but oh I gotta get on my horse
isn't there
what are we gonna do about the bear
aim weapon RT
s of it
all right all right I guess we won't
shoot it could be cocaine bear it looks
like okay bear look how big it is
actually in the at the trailer for
cocaine bear the cocaine bear doesn't
look big he doesn't you look kind of
scary well he's a CGI no yeah I
understand this but thank you I think
they realize they can't make the cocaine
bear fat because then
because then he would be lazy yeah it
would be slow moving you have to have
like a
skinny agile Bear yeah like just woke up
from hibernation yeah took some cocaine
I
really want to see that movie just to
see like how far they take it like how
can you have a movie for two hours on a
premise that feels like it should not
last longer it feels like a joke that
you
amongst friends for like 10 minutes and
like maximum 10 minutes like you have
like this weird banter about it and it
gets weird after like three minutes
so literally
so but this is based on a true story
right
so literally
it is it is there was some cocaine in
the woods dropped off in the woods all
right so they're gonna do that and
they're gonna say oh it looks like some
bear ate into it okay that takes like
two minutes to introduce
maybe half the movie is just like the
cocaine story
you know it could be
or maybe like looking at how the cocaine
changes the relationship the bear has
with his family
and other Bears going like The Lion King
way yeah I don't know
it's a very silly movie
it could be like a cool action film
maybe they're going like I think they
might be hilarious kills a bunch of like
the bear kills a bunch of people I
almost hope that it's really dumb
because I think it would be funnier that
way I hope William Nielsen isn't it
he made a job mistake you're stealing my
daughter that would be great he would
call the bear is that the guy from Taken
yeah taken yeah yeah it's I am a sucker
for those movies
taking all of them he's he's in a bunch
of them he plays the same exact guy and
he is such a badass those movies freaked
me out
I think it was probably a good thing
I'd love to talk to on the podcast he's
a really really interesting dude and he
like
same with uh what's the guy from
Breaking Bad
um
I don't know his name but anything
you're talking about Aaron something
that's a blonde guy the older guy I
don't know what his name is he Brian
Cranston I want to say he's like a
badass in real life too like I like it
when you're like
when you don't just play the part like
it's part of who you are well I feel
like playing the part
made him more of a badass and he
embraced it the part changed him and
that's really cool I mean when you play
a meth dealer
for like 10 seasons whatever it is it's
gonna change you yeah definitely
I mean it'd be it's part of you now
it's like when you do any job it becomes
it consumes you
yeah
you like you like you've been working
like crazy right I work a lot yeah I
work like 60 or 70 hours a week
good I love it hard work is good yeah
it's important
kitchen is that any way to greet an old
friend I feel like we haven't spoken for
days I do my utmost to avoid he loves me
really is sadly a showing
affection no it isn't now shoot get lost
well see you gents later see you it's
interesting you know when you spend 60
or 70 hours a week doing something
because before that I wasn't working
it's like become my entire life it's all
that I think about to the point that
sometimes when I I'll go to a restaurant
I'll see an elderly person a person
who's having a hard time walking and I'm
like I should be in a lab working like
what am I doing yeah yeah why am I here
that's really good that means you really
care about it there's I mean you were
talking about it when I met you about
Prosthetics and all that kind of stuff
that was a passion yeah it's cool that
you like found that passion in this work
it's great yeah
I'm skinning a deer
here we go
I'm kidding did you have to press
something just why
did you do any animal work
ever
uh yeah dissecting in uh High School
yeah
yeah for anatomy and physiology
yeah that's funny
I missed I miss high school for like the
educational aspects
were you funny in high school
what were you like in high school uh
very like stoic very read a lot and uh
wrestling and sports and just
that was there any book that really
shaped you in high school
yeah like a lot a lot of
first it was like the stranger which is
probably by Albert Camus he uh
it's like I just reread it recently and
it's not nearly as good as when you read
it in those forms I've read other books
that I've read it and they're much
better or is it not as good in
comparison to the books that you've read
yeah after that you see there's other
books like like Dusty Esky gets better
and better as I get older and I read
that in high school but the stranger was
like yeah
but it's the first time I had this exit
feeling of existentialism of like
it's the first time I really intensely
felt like what was the meaning of it all
I felt it not just like an existential
yeah
interesting
and then of course you like take it like
way too seriously yeah and you get like
really depressed and nervous and yeah
[Music]
you're the one that really hit me is
Animal Farms oh that's a great book can
he tell you which character I like the
most and then you tell me which one you
like the most
can you guess
uh uh well it's not the pigs
is it is it the the the molly the horse
that likes pretty uh how dare you
uh Benjamin the donkey who's cynical
about everything no
um I feel like it's obvious
ly it's boxer oh yeah
you're just working harder yeah
yeah obviously it's mine too
he's stealing my best my my is that your
My Vibe yeah
yeah we'll work harder but I think hard
work is a lot more important than
because human intelligence doesn't vary
all that much
like when you're smart
I mean there's only like you can't get
much smarter
do you think hard work Beats
the cliche Talent yeah I think like a
combination of the two probably or like
even just being passionate yeah and
putting in the work because you could be
passionate and lazy
Let's Ride
and I think sometimes if you think
you're really smart it kind of uh holds
you back
to where you feel like you don't have to
try as hard
[Music]
but then it leads to like a very
I think boring life but who knows for
some people they enjoy that
this is a straight up a movie yeah it's
beautiful what do you uh what do you
what do you think is the meaning of life
what do I think is the meaning of life
I think it's a good thing to ask while
we're listening we're watching a bunch
of cowboys ride
through the woods I think nothing in
life matters except for love and human
connection
[Music]
like nothing else is really all that
important
like I think when you look back on life
you look back on the moments that you
shared with other people How Deeply you
love them How Deeply you felt things
I think all of that is important
everything else is just noise
I agree this is really beautiful is it
the seasons are changing
yeah before our eyes
what do you think is the meaning of life
how good you can ride a horse
and how pretty you look in a cowboy hat
it's probably it
um so it's not wearing
shorts Barefoot on a beach
on a horse
when the feeling strikes you
can't take a ridiculous photo of me it's
my favorite photo on a horse I've ever
seen him a person
yeah it's a fabulous photo the funny
thing is there's a bunch of shirtless
versions of that there's shirtless
versions it was like you know almost
like ridiculous because I rode the horse
shirtless but then I put on a shirt this
is like too ridiculous to take a picture
of like what are you doing it was it was
cool like riding a horse on Sand is is a
different experience
it's like looking out over the ocean
it's cool it's an incredible feeling why
did you just shoot a gun
okay
[Laughter]
sorry this is how
okay all bad things happen this is why
we can't have nice things I think this
is
a good place to end it yeah I think so
too
uh we'll game should we play next time
um you have ideas
maybe we'll play GTA
could be
good thought
what's your big takeaway from this
journey we took together
[Music]
would you like to get I love the game
I love it too but it's also like it's
almost nostalgic
yeah
that would be fun nostalgic like
personally for you like yeah
oh I see you used to play this I thought
you meant like you takes me back it
takes me back I used to my old days when
I used to ride horses in summer camp me
too
let's go Mexico
I don't talk about that
the things I've seen the things These
Eyes I've seen
foreign